you look amazing as always tell me one
secret about this look tonight
um Gianni Versace this is actually from
the fall winter
take a peek in there and I'm immensely
grateful because I never really saw
myself being able to wear a piece like
this and it's really beautiful and I
feel very good you're a walking piece of
art it's something else it's so cute
it's the dress Versace well it's also
your moment I mean you're a first time
nominee and not only that but you're
being recognized by fellow actors and
your peers how does that feel
it's very surreal I think um I respect a
lot of the people in this room and a lot
of the people who are a part of
sag so I think that to be exposed to
them and get to interact with them yeah
well I had never really been to an event
as big as the Globes I don't think so
that was kind of shocking yeah but this
is a bit more intimate which is which is
nice there's so much to talk to you
about okay you're hosting SNL soon any
nerves oh 100
different world I'm nervous wreck and
it's so funny because everyone is
prepping me for it and they're like yeah
any of our clients who have worked for
us and now I said that it's the most
stressful week of their life have called
us crying oh my God I don't know what to
do I don't know if I'm funny enough I
don't know if I'm this enough so I feel
like I've only heard
scary things so I think that when I get
there it'll be delightful and fun and
wonderful I heard the final night is
like right it's an adrenaline yeah it's
a career Milestone but also I would have
to say you're pretty Fearless as an
artist so it's like this is the next
thing you know well I'm excited I I
would love to do more play work and
things like that so to be able to
interact with an audience like that I
think is really really beneficial and
that's what what I'm most excited for I
think is to feed off of a crowd well
until then we're excited for Scream Six
I can't believe it's six in the trilogy
new city new rules uh what do you hope
fans take away from this movie
um I think that Ghostface is a lot more
of a scary figure I feel like we've
always seen him as like kind of a clumsy
funny almost killer where I think in
this one he's actually a lot of the
deaths are very visceral and very
um kind of tragic in a sense which is
kind of brought in this more dramatic
atmosphere but I still think we do a
good job of balancing comedy and stuff
like this but I think audiences should
be prepared for it to be a bit more of a
roller coaster more than anything real
quick the used showrunner recently
revealed that they try to get you for
the fourth season uh I mean what
happened there oh I was devastated
you're talking about Sarah gamble yeah
love her easily one of my favorite sets
that I've ever ever been on I was so
devastated when they reached out because
I had one I I Miss Ellie and I had been
wanting to go back to Ellie for such a
long time but I was in Romania shooting
Wednesday and I couldn't I I couldn't
travel back and forth with the pandemic
and everything like that and when you're
committed to a show there was just no
way that it could have worked out but
that one was that bummed me out hard to
say no too yeah they're hard to pass on
because of schedule yeah well I tried I
tried I tried now you're a sag nominee
so I think it was worth it
[Music]
foreign